And to this SVG, we can begin inserting shapes.
Let us revisit what we know about visual encodings, and try to
recreate one circle from the Gapminder Wealth & Health of Nations example.
Let us start by trying to recreate the circle that represents China.
As you can see here, China has a life expectancy of 75 years and
income per person, GDP per capita of 8,347 and
a total population of 1.35 billion.
When faced with creating any visualization based on data,
you need to figure out a way to transform data values, in this case,
life expectancy of 75, income per person of 8347,
into the appropriate coordinates on the x and y plane.
Since we're building a visualization in the browser,
we often have to map the values of our data to pixel values.
Since D3 was created exactly for this purpose, it has many convenience functions
for converting data values into its corresponding pixel value.
The most commonly used functions for
this purpose in D3 can be found in the d3.scale module.